u.s is sending thousands more troops to
saudi arabia you'll remember it already
sent hundreds
over the summer as tension with iran and
elsewhere in the region increased
now the pentagon has confirmed a
deployment of 3 000 troops
let's talk to roslyn jordan now in
washington dc is following developments
here roslyn
well kamal i'm just getting through this
statement just as
you and our viewers are and we should
run through
some of the material that's going along
with the 3 000
u.s troops to saudi arabia
they are deploying two fighter jet
squadrons
one air expeditionary wing two patriot
anti-missile
defense systems as well as one fad
uh missile defense system that's the
more uh that's the one that deals with
uh
missiles coming in from a higher
altitude and most
recently we saw the deployment of three
such
fad air missile defense systems to south
korea to
respond to any potential threat from
north korea
this is a significant ramp up but
the u.s says it is carrying out this
action kamal
in order to protect its uh ally saudi
arabia from
threats in the region and i'm just
reading i think the same statement roswe
they say the united states does not seek
conflict with
the iranian regime this i mean it starts
to feel a little
different though doesn't it i mean
already over the summer there was
concern at the
increase of hundreds of troops now
thousands
well certainly you know the u.s has been
uh very slowly uh
adding more military presence
in the gulf region because of what it
calls iran's
malign behavior but certainly after the
september 14th attack on aramco
facilities
in the far eastern part of saudi arabia
and the determination by a number of
intelligence agencies not just from the
u.s but from in europe as well
that it had to have been the iranians
behind that attack
that you are seeing this uh increased
u.s presence on saudi soil it had been
quite uh politically sensitive for u.s
forces to be located
inside saudi arabia and some may recall
that that was one of the reasons of why
al qaeda
formed and was acting in attacks
against so many western and so many
saudi interests the
opposition to the presence of u.s forces
on saudi soil
according to al-qaeda was seen as
sacrilegious
but certainly in light of the ongoing
tensions between washington and tehran
this is a significant ramp up and
certainly
we understand that there may be some
sort of uh briefing
from pentagon officials about the
decision to send 3 000
troops to saudi arabia where they might
be able to give
more context into why they've decided to
do this and why now it's been almost
a month since the oil fields and oil
processing facilities in eastern saudi
arabia
were attacked why now okay
rosalind jordan in washington thank you